[Music]
[Music]
it's seven o'clock this is sky news
breakfast these are our top stories this
morning
you haven't missed your chance the top
four priority groups urged to come
forward for a covid19 jab
as ministers make a final push to hit
monday's vaccine target
senators could vote later in donald
trump's second impeachment trial as his
defense calls the proceedings
an act of political hatred
kovid's addiction impact warnings the
national lockdown is leading to a rise
in families seeking help for people with
alcohol
and drug issues you just sort of can't
see the end i think
it's the hopelessness of it and there's
not an end point
we need a clear plan calls from the
wedding industry
for a route forward with 200 000
weddings still postponed from last year
in the sport england's cricketers have
made a strong start to the second test
against india we've got all the action
from chennai and it's time to say
goodbye to the snow but not just yet
it will be a little wintry over the
weekend but by monday some parts could
be seeing temperatures in double figures
and at quarter to eight we'll take a
look at the newspapers with the
journalist and broadcaster bedicia and
the comedian
andrew doyle
[Music]
good morning welcome to sky news
breakfast thank you for joining us a
final push is underway to ensure
everyone in the top four priority groups
comes forward for a covid19 vaccine the
uk-wide target is to offer vaccines to
15 million people by monday
people aged 70 and over care home
residents and staff
healthcare workers and the clinically
extremely vulnerable
england and wales have now met that
target and ministers are making a fresh
bid to increase
uptake and tackle misinformation in some
groups
becky cottrell reports
as vaccinators continue to battle the
virus the numbers are going
in the right direction the infection
rate has shrunk to a level last seen in
summer
and jab uptake has been extremely high
among priority
vulnerable groups as the government
looks to inoculate the over 65s
a fresh plea to anyone who is eligible
but reluctant to join over 14 million
people
who've already been vaccinated if you're
in one of those groups
what i'd say is please come forward if
you haven't already got an appointment
to be jabbed
because the more people who get this job
the safer everybody is
the messaging particularly targeted at
bame communities
who are more likely to become severely
ill with covert but
less likely to get a jab at this clinic
in north west london
optimism and resignation i did my own
research and i'm
very satisfied with everything we all
have to take care of each other so
they're telling us that it's safe so we
will i'm fine with it
it's one of those things i think i
should get but i'm not
too sure whether it'll work or not
uptake for the vaccine has exceeded
government expectations
but no one can afford to be complacent a
doctor here told me that they were in a
race against time to protect this
community
he says messaging from gps and local
healthcare providers is vital
in continuing to build trust in the
rollout
especially in the face of a mutating
enemy as surge testing for the south
african variant begins in middlesbrough
a direct message from the government to
the most vulnerable
it is not too late to get a vaccine
becky cottrell
sky news north west london
well our political correspondent rob
hall joins us now from westminster
and rob the vaccination program uh
moving ahead at pace it's been very
successful but the health secretary this
morning saying that
we actually need to live with covid19 in
the same way that we do
with the flu yeah matt hancock's given
an interview to the daily telegraph
which you can probably read in either an
optimistic or a pessimistic way i think
the optimistic part of it is that matt
hancock says
that by the end of the year covert 19
should be a treatable disease and that
vaccines and treatments mean that it
will be an illness we can live with
um like we do the flu so i think an
indication that
this isn't going away that the
vaccination program isn't just going to
banish covert 19
from all of our lives forever but that
going forward
how we manage it will change that the
vaccine program will bring an end to the
pandemic stage
of covid how we've been experiencing it
for the last year
but it may well come back and cause
pressures for the nhs every winter like
seasonal flu does
that treatments which the uk has been at
the forefront of
uh discovering and trialling will play a
part
as well especially in those where the
vaccine does not
work so that's the long term in the
short term clearly the focus
is on what vaccine this vaccine success
means for the lifting
of restrictions and i think in both
scientific and political circles
there is a good deal of optimism uh
probably mixed with a hefty dose
of relief that cases are coming down
that the reproduction rate
is below one the lowest since summer
last year that the epidemic
is shrinking the issue is we are coming
down from a very
high level of infections you just look
at the number of people in hospital with
covert 19
and it is still above the peak level it
was at
last april in the first wave peak and
that is why scientists are all urging
caution when it comes to lifting
restrictions
they are saying that this needs to be
done gradually in a step-by-step basis
with government pausing after reopening
certain sectors
or taking certain measures to gauge the
impact that has had
on infection spread and also warning
that some
lower down measures like face masks like
some social distancing
may be needed right through until winter
now that might be
uh too slow and too cautious for some
here in westminster
okay rob thank you let's take a look at
the latest
uk coronavirus figures now and 15 144
new confirmed cases of covet 19
were recorded in the most recent 24-hour
period
and a further 758 people have died
within 28 days of testing positive
bringing the uk total to 116 287.
so far more than 14 million first doses
of a vaccine
have been administered
u.s senators could vote later today on
whether to convict or acquit
donald trump in his impeachment trial
over last month's capital riots
the former president's lawyers have said
democrats are waging a campaign of
hatred against
him and say the language he used before
the insurrection was ordinary political
rhetoric
adam parsons reports from washington dc
who was responsible for this
the attack on the u.s capitol was
vicious and shocking
this trial has given us new insights
into the mayhem
the vice president and his family being
rushed from a hiding place as the mob
called for him to be
hanged republican senator mitt romney
being told to run away
but was all this really caused by the
words of one man
democrats have alleged that after years
of inflammatory rhetoric by donald trump
this was the moment that turned a
protest into a riot
you fight like hell and if you don't
fight like hell you're not going to have
a country anymore
mr trump's lawyers insist it's absurd to
blame
him for the attack on the capital the
article of impeachment
now before the senate is an unjust
and blatantly unconstitutional act
of political vengeance this is ordinary
political rhetoric that is virtually
indistinguishable from the language that
has been used
by people across the political spectrum
for
hundreds of years this is a fight
fighting
i think they mocked the idea that the
word fight could be so dangerous
with a long video of democrats using
exactly the same word
fight of their lives we are in this
fight for
our lives we cannot ever get
up fighting but democrat prosecutors
here are unrepentant
in their caustic criticism of the former
president and he has at
every opportunity encouraged and
cultivated
actual violence by these groups
yes he has encouraged actual
violence not just the word fight
mr trump has been in florida playing
golf but also
following events as they unfold in the
senate
you can still see the scars of that mob
attack here in washington dc
this fence was hastily erected it runs
for several miles with razor wire on top
and hundreds of troops on the other side
all here
to defend the capital the building
that was attacked but which now houses
the senators who will cast their verdict
on the future of donald trump
very few expect him to be convicted if
he were it would be
extraordinary america is waiting to see
what happens next
adam parsons sky news washington
let's look at the other stories making
the news this morning and mario draghi
has
formally accepted the role of italy's
next prime minister
the former european central bank chief
submitted the names of his cabinet
yesterday
replacing giuseppe conte's centre-left
coalition that collapsed
last month thousands of doctors across
the uk
say they haven't been properly protected
against covid19 since the start of the
pandemic
a poll by the british medical
association found fewer than 28 percent
of health professionals
feel entirely safe at work the
association says the findings are
unacceptable and tell a story of real
worry
amongst medics the home of everton
manager carlo ancelotti has reportedly
been raided by mast
burglars police have confirmed two men
wearing black balaclavas broke into a
house in crosby yesterday evening
it's believed the italian's daughter was
inside the property at the time
police said a safe was taken but the
occupants weren't
hurt addiction services are warning
there's been a significant rise in the
number of people getting help for drug
and alcohol problems during this
lockdown
charity action on addiction say they've
seen an 86
increase in the number of people seeking
assistance for addiction issues compared
to january
last year ashley haring reports
it's scary being in a locked space or
a you know an enclosed space with
someone that's struggling like that
having someone that can fall down the
stairs or
has breathing issues you know you're
constantly scared that they're going to
die
naomi's dad is alcohol and drug
dependent
he has bounced between sobriety and
traumatic behavior her whole life
but this second national lockdown has
exacerbated his addictions
i mean january february for anyone with
mental health issues is really hard
anyway
and i think all the small things that
gave shape to his life
have now been stripped away he had a
relapse on
first of jan and it's kind of been
ongoing since then
um with hospital admissions and two
hospital admissions
an overdose um
yeah and you just sort of can't see the
end i think
it's the hopelessness of it and there's
not an end point
addiction is an illness in isolation and
when the entire country is cocooned in
lockdown
it gives the most perilous of issues
space to thrive a survey of the families
of substance users shows that since the
first
lockdown 85 percent of families have
struggled more with helping their loved
one
almost half witnessed increased alcohol
or drug
use another charity says they've seen an
86
rise in the number of people seeking
help this january
compared to last hello everyone and but
the help available
looks very different thank you all for
taking the time out of your day
practitioner katie helps the families of
people with drug and alcohol issues
the anonymity of joining virtual support
groups
can be comforting but some are missing
out
we can't give the frontline care because
we are unable to run the
the groups within lockdown we can run
them via zoom sessions
but obviously there it doesn't work in
the same way
it doesn't have the same feeling for
people there's not that same level of
support
we can't even offer somebody a cup of
tea and a biscuit if they come to a
support group
which is really key to making people
feel welcome
charities are striving to do better but
resources are limited
there is some help out there i of course
would say there's not enough what we're
doing at ad farm is
campaigning and trying to fundraise so
we can offer more and more help for
these families
but it's still i think we still we're on
a journey and we still have a way to go
naomi's dad is currently in hospital
recovering from his latest
overdose whilst it's respite for her and
her mum
they miss him dearly for many the end of
lockdown means renewed freedoms
but for millions with dependency issues
it would also mean stopping this
triggering period
in its tracks ashna harinag sky news
and just reminder our series of special
programmes covid crisis learning the
lessons where we delve into the data and
main talking points from over the past
year
is available to watch again throughout
the day here on
sky news returning to the u.s now and
senators could vote later today on
whether to convict or acquit donald
trump
in his impeachment trial over last
month's capital rights
let's speak to the associate editor of
the hill nile stanage uh who joins us
from washington dc good morning to you
and
what have you made of the management of
the impeachment trial
thus far i think democrats have made a
very
effective case jillian they spent
approximately three days
really setting out the context as they
see it
mr trump's history of inflammatory
remarks
his remarks in particular at a speech on
the day of the cattle insurrection
that they believe directly led and
fueled those events
mr trump's defense honestly has been a
little bit more uncertain particularly
in the early stages
but it did do better the the defense
team did do better
earlier well about 12 hours ago my time
in terms of trying to present some sort
of justification
yes and the defense uh claiming that
this type of rhetoric has been used
equally by
the the democrats and their their
compilation of democrats saying that
they must fight
for what they believe in so they're
suggesting that it isn't uh
anyway abnormal that donald trump should
have used language like that
yes that's right they're making the
argument that it is basically
standard political rhetoric to speak in
this way
i think that that was more effective
with some specific comments than others
there was for example a comment by nancy
pelosi the democratic speaker of the
house of representatives seeming to
welcome
uprisings or another democratic
congresswoman talking approvingly of
unrest in relation to issues of social
justice here
but i think the point about fight was a
bit
thinner honestly because really it's mr
trump's history
that plays into all this a politician at
random
saying he or she should fight for a
particular cause
doesn't really seem the same thing as mr
trump's record to me
do you think that any republicans will
be persuaded um by what they've heard
so far to to go against donald trump at
this point
at the moment jillian i think the
maximum you're going to get
is five or six republican senators out
of 50.
and i take that view because that's the
number who voted at the outset of this
trial
to say that it was even constitutional
the vast
bulk of republican senators held to the
view that it's not even constitutional
to try
the former president in this way now
among those five or six we have people
who have shown
a capacity and willingness to criticize
mr trump people like mitt romney
susan collins lisa murkowski those are
the people who are most likely
to cross party lines of course that
would not be enough
to convict the former president and if
he
is cleared um is it a foregone
conclusion that he will be able to run
for political office again should he so
desire to do
it is more or less yes i mean basically
you need to be convicted before
a separate measure can be brought
barring you from federal office
the conviction as many of your viewers
will know requires a two-thirds majority
in the senate
so it's highly unlikely that that first
higher bar
will be cleared to convict trump and
therefore
he would be willing or would be able to
seek office again
i do think though in fairness he has
been politically damaged
by the events that we have seen over the
past couple of months and his role in
them
if he is cleared it will leave many
people uh questioning
whether an impeachment should have been
held at all
do you think that that it still has
served a purpose even if he is cleared
i think it has first of all it's clearly
has not
hurt democrats the polling that we see
tends to show small majorities or
pluralities in favor of convicting
donald trump
so there's no real sense that the
democrats have overreached in that
regard
and i do think that if he is acquitted
as is almost certain
it does still put a mark or
asterisk against his name in the history
books that he is the only
president in american history to have
been impeached twice
even though no president including him
looks like
has ever been convicted okay well thank
you very much for sharing your insight
with us good to speak to you this
morning thanks jillian
time now for a look at the weather with
the joe hi there
hello it's looking a little bit
different for next week
it's going to get milder but um we have
still got a few wintry hazards to
overcome this weekend and it is going to
feel bitterly cold in fact colder than
it has done
for quite a few days on account of the
strong winds let's take a look at the
details
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
hello there good morning to you so what
we have is this cold air across the
country
you might have noticed it and then
milder conditions trying to come in from
the west
and those milder conditions are born in
on this rain and these
freshening winds so we've got gusts to
around 60 miles per hour
over some western areas this morning but
also strong gusts over eastern areas
where temperatures once again
are sub-zero and will barely rise above
freezing through the day so there's your
wind chill factor
it will feel quite unpleasant even in
those areas where you think you have
some sunshine
the rain is already over parts of
ireland and as it's run into this cold
air it's turned to snow
on its leading edge not just snow but we
could see some freezing rain as well now
that's
deeply unpleasant it's where rain falls
on frozen surfaces
and freezes on contact so very
treacherous for motorcyclists
motorists and also pedestrians through
the course of the day then this tries to
move its way eastwards it makes very
slow progress a little bit of snow to
come for parts of wales and the
southwest as well
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
still to come we have all the sport with
jackie this morning hello there
good morning jillian england's
cricketers have made a very strong start
to the second test against
india in chennai we've got all the
action coming up all those wickets
also we will show you who came out on
top in the manchester derby with a big
result
in the race for the women's super league
title
and will england respond to defeating
their six nations
opener with victory today we're going to
be hearing from the
england camp and the scotland camp as
well
[Music]
i don't know if i'd say it was love at
first face time he was actually an hour
late for our first
virtual date um but it did get better
and we ended up talking until three in
the morning that night
um and then we just we basically just
carried on having loads of facetimes
messages for three weeks um
and yeah i think i did i did it sounds
really cheesy but i think i had
fallen in love with him on paper or over
facetime before i'd even met him
finally um we were able to meet at
social distance
last summer after like all these virtual
dates and
yeah it sounds ridiculous but as soon as
i saw him i just felt completely
comfortable with him and completely like
yeah this is this is the one
what makes any of us fall in love at any
point i think it's like
a hundred thousand different things
isn't it it's like it wasn't the way he
looked or
any particular thing he said it was just
like it was like
it was just a chemistry it's just a
spark between us um
and then it was just confirmed basically
when we when we did finally meet up i
think we both just felt like
yeah this this was real it wasn't just
uh it wasn't just
a facetime fantasy we were just sat
by a riverbank and we were just eating
crisps and he
said uh oh lorna um will you marry me
and i was like yeah definitely um but it
was honestly like
when i was trying to explain it to
friends and family the next day like
i didn't really mean to get engaged it
was more like if you'd asked me if i
wanted a cup of tea
or to stroke a cat or something like the
answer's always going to be yes
oh here he comes now he's trying to join
me now
i know it sounds ridiculous it really it
really felt like like the most
normal thing in the world and it's i
think it's only it's caused a bit of a
fuss really
um that we didn't realize in retrospect
actually it does seem insane doesn't it
[Music]
yes
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
time for a look at the sport coming up
with uh jackie and all the very latest
with the cricket hi there
yes morning julian um it is it's
actually lovely to wake up to some sport
actually going on and it has been a good
start the second test for england there
have been wickets let's have a look
this sports bulletin is brought to you
by vitality
committed to getting 100 million people
20 more active by 2025
the world is changing and i'm really
afraid that
being selfish can be our worst mistake
and i cannot allow it
when you think that you are not able to
provide food to your family
i think that's the worst feeling that
someone has
wolves managing luna espirito santo like
all of us has been profoundly affected
by the pandemic
he wanted to help and approach the
club's foundation with his offer
the result is a 250 000 pounds donation
to feed the pack a project aimed at
reducing food poverty
in a city where 29 of children are
living in poverty
it's a common project now it's it's
everybody that wants
um to help everybody in wolves
that can give a hand you will do so
it's just a beginning it was great that
he decided that he wanted to support
a project and support the city
ultimately we initially explored a few
ideas about
the type of projects that we could work
together
on um and we kept coming back to the
need for supporting people with food at
this most difficult time so
um in the end you know we it was it was
so sort of emotive the whole topic
um that you know it was it was the one
that we chose out of all the other
options
what do you want to achieve from the
project and what do you think it can
achieve
i think it can involve many many people
it can involve
everyone
[Music]
companies
individual and it can bring a spirit
that
we need to to support each other now as
a pack
and when i speak about pec is not only
our friends it's uh it's the city
football has played on through lockdowns
but nuno and his staff have not been
desensitized to society's problems
not having fans here not having that
presence
it's a big blow it's a big blow but it's
not
so big as we are experienced
and besides football
the society and the world is on problems
you can see
you just turn on the news and you you
get frightened
so and with all these doubts in the
in the future of the people um
it's a moment that showed that that's a
light that's we're gonna go through this
we just need to stake to stick together
to
stay close to each other to not being
selfish
uh this is not the right moment to think
about
individuals to think about as a whole is
to think about
we which future we want
for the further generations in front of
us this pandemic
will will leave big scars in our lives
and let's try to to make it make it
easier for everybody do you think what
you're doing now and what the
feed the pack project will do is
give people a sense of community that
may not have had it before as well when
people go through
abject poverty they may feel alone
exactly that's
let's not allow them to feel alone let's
give them the sense and the the feeling
that they
have someone and us as a club as a
foundation it's the right moment to do
[Music]
it
it was tough it was brave
it was i didn't quite understand at that
time
what was happening because you know
he was kneeling during the national
anthem
so part of me i thought that was
disrespectful
but then i looked into the the bigger
picture of wiley
he was kneeling you know for police
brutality
inequality and for someone to put his
whole life on the line for the better
of the people like he's just inspiration
at a time when
doing that was one of the worst possible
times to do it when there's significant
change and i feel like that flag
represents what's supposed to represent
in this country is representing
people the way that it's supposed to
i'll stand he probably had death threats
probably had you know his life was
probably hell
and for him to do that when it wasn't
fashionable
to do it and just do it for the right
reasons i can't have no more respect for
him
that wouldn't happen in this country not
a chance would i put my whole
career on the line for the greater good
at that time without having to think
about it
probably not so for him to do that it's
just inspirational character
really is everyone's talking about this
black lives matter and this neither but
people are talking about now because
it's fashionable like to do that to get
on a knee when
and i know there's a couple other
players at the time but for him to do
that by himself
like he's just i can't put into words
the amount of respect i have for him and
you just said that people are talking
about the black lives matter
because it's fashionable does that anger
you does that please you
does that make you feel better that
there's greater awareness
what are your emotions players are
kneeling for equality
and that's it a powerful image
to show football's social conscience
as all of the players take the need
committed to getting 100 million people
20 more active by 2025
[Music]
this is sky news breakfast coming up
the singer who overcame a speech
impediment to follow his
dream will be singing at twickenham
later on today
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to sky news breakfast our
top stories this morning the government
has launched a new campaign to reach
those at risk groups who may not yet
have taken up the offer to get a kobit
19 vaccine
it comes as ministers make a final push
to hit monday's vaccine target of
offering the jab to 50 million people
donald trump's defence team in his
second impeachment trial have accused
the democrats of waging a campaign of
hatred against him
u.s senators could vote later today on
whether to convict or equip donald trump
in his impeachment trial over last
month's capital rise
and there's a warning from addiction
services that the number of people
seeking help for drug and alcohol
problems is rising
during the latest lockdown
the wedding industry is calling on the
government to include it in the roadmap
out of lockdown that will be announced
by the prime minister on the 22nd of
february
around 200 000 weddings from last year
still haven't happened
and the industry is warning that they
need targeted financial support and a
clear route forward
aisha zahid has this story
liz normally does 50 weddings a year but
in 2020
only five went ahead the pandemic has
left her with less than 10
of her annual income i'm doing all i can
to keep my business here
um and keep it alive because i've got
couples that are waiting for me to be
able to do their weddings later this
year but it's expensive
paying out each month for things that i
can't use and i'm not i'm not likely to
use for a while
critics say there hasn't been enough
support from the government
it's an industry worth more than 14
billion pounds
and the pandemic has left many
businesses within it struggling
with more than 500 000 weddings in the
pipeline for this year
the continued uncertainty ahead is a big
concern for many
and a number of those working in the
sector are calling for
weddings to be recognized in the road
map out of lockdown
the wedding industry needs a clear plan
as to when we can open
and to how many guests and we need
support
we have been unable to trade in a
commercially viable form
for nearly a year and the infrastructure
at the very heart of our sector
is due to collapse holly and chris
exchanged their vows in a ceremony last
october
but only 15 people were legally allowed
to attend
they hoped to put on a bigger event this
summer but have been forced to postpone
it
until next year it's been really hard i
mean luckily we've had a good
good distraction with rosie
but it has been really difficult for
businesses and couples alike
hopes now lie on the current
restrictions being reviewed
aisha zahid sky news
the england rugby team play italy in the
six nations later on today
rodney earl clark will open the match
with the national anthem
the singer overcame a speech impediment
to reach this point in his career and
helps others to overcome
similar challenges before we speak to
him let's take a listen to his latest
[Music]
single
[Music]
rodney earl clark joins us now good
morning to you
um how are you feeling before your big
debut
in front of an audience of millions good
morning jillian
uh thanks very much for having me on
your show i've got to be honest with you
i didn't get much sleep last night with
all the excitement but i'm sure that
it's going to be
a wonderful day a little bit nervous
then but i mean you shouldn't be phased
you've performed at the royal festival
hall
um you've performed with people like
michael ball
you've got quite a a lot of um
experience to your credit
that's right i've been um been able to
perform for many years
uh in some wonderful places but of
course
with the lockdown you know we're all a
bit out out of practice and um
i've got to say to my fellow colleagues
out there and i really do
appreciate um how tough it has been and
how lucky and fortunate i am
indeed to be able to perform uh during
these circumstances
yes as you say many of your colleagues
not able to perform
during lockdown um what are some of the
things that that you've been doing have
you
gone for an online audience so what have
you been doing to get through this time
yes well apart from uh the initial
lockdown where i kind of
tried my hand at diy as i'm sure quite a
lot of us did
um i really said about trying to kind of
reflect on
reflect as to why i do what i do
and of course um sharing my experiences
and my expertise online
and um it's quite remarkable because
you've overcome
a speech impediment uh for you to be
performing at this level tell us about
that and how you you overcame it
yes well i've been stuttering from the
age of 12 and uh i never really much
kind of had the opportunity or indeed
felt the opportunity to
express myself and communicate properly
or as
how i wanted to but um i noticed a
drastic change in the
way i spoke when i attended the royal
academy of music
studying singing there and it became
really apparent to me that
through that course i learned how to
breathe properly to have to breathe like
an opera singer
and those breathing techniques really
helped me
uh to iron out the bumps in my speech
and
uh with this in mind i kind of really
thought that it was a
marvelous opportunity for me to uh try
and help others
in doing the same and i've
organized and devised an online uh
course
called singing speaking to help people
with their fluency
now are you a rugby fan um i i do
appreciate rugby it's an amazing
spectator sport and i'll
tell you a little secret and now um i
used to play rugby at school and my
mother always used to laugh at how clean
my rugby kit was
when i brought it home because uh
obviously that means you weren't very
good
no i was a center and i was very fast
so they couldn't they couldn't catch you
now i'm going to be a bit cheeky
um can you give us a bit of a blast this
morning i know you probably haven't
warmed up yet
of what people can expect later well you
know i'm always of the opinion that you
know i want to
save a bit and you know it's i didn't
get much sleep last night and
i don't want to disappoint but i really
want to encourage people to tune in and
to really see me singing
the national anthem so on this occasion
i'm actually going to save my voice
oh you're teasing us
rodney l clark you've wetted the
appetite we shall be keenly listening
later on uh good luck
thanks for speaking so much take care
okay from one musician to another she's
a bit of a dab hand at the piano you
know
aren't you it's rumored so it's said
that's all because of the uh the lock
down weather in front of my piano
anyway to the weather which is really
quite important this weekend because
it's all change
time to say goodbye to the wintry
conditions not just yet
wait for it but by monday we could well
be seeing temperatures and double
figures
let's take a look
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
hello there good morning to you well the
situation this uh weekend
is that we've got cold air over the
country you may well have noticed it
and now we've got mild conditions trying
to come in but of course as this rain
makes its way off the atlantic it's
turning to sleet snow
and freezing rain on its leading edge
and so
we do have warning outs again for the
sleet the snow
the frost the ice because temperatures
once again are sub-zero to start the day
not as cold as they have been but still
saw
minus 12 over scotland so through the
course of the day the central and
eastern area is likely to see some
sunshine but daytime temperatures
only around zero or one and to go with
that we've got a very strong
wind that wind gusting 45 to 50 miles
per hour
over those eastern coasts so a
significant wind chill factor
a similar situation in the west in fact
the winds are stronger
gusting to around 60 miles per hour but
we're starting to see this milder air
coming in
three or four for those west eastern
parts
and 11 down in the southwest so that's
52 degrees fahrenheit
but uh certainly northern ireland like
to see some blizzard conditions today
with those strong winds
and that rain turning to snow on its
leading edge laws of
winter-ness across parts of wales and
the southwest could see some freezing
rain which is quite unusual
it's rain that freezes on contact with
frozen surfaces very very dodgy
in terms of traveling but a lot of that
dies out as we go through the day
further wet weather to the northwest
overnight another cold one to come for
many
showers and longer spells of rain
pushing eastwards and eventually that
milder air arrives
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
at 7 43 you're watching sky news
breakfast after the break we'll take a
look at the newspapers and the stories
making the front pages do stay with us
for the early risers
for the knowledge seekers
for the straight talkers the curious and
the ones who want to be entertained
backstage sky news
entertainment podcast but wherever you
are welcome to youtube safely
for the ones who want to know more
welcome to the all out politics podcast
for the listeners from sky news
sky news podcasts listen and subscribe
for free
i'm stuart ramsey and i'm sky's chief
correspondent
we help you understand the world with us
stuart ramsey sky news there is a life
skill
and you know in this country we've made
a very sensible decision
um that every child should learn how to
swim
and of course uh during this uh this
past year
uh it's really been disrupted and uh
there have been very very
few swimming lessons and when the
swimming pools opened
there were more than ten percent of
swimming pools that didn't
open and there's great concern that many
of those pools will not open ever
again and um so you know for
for this generation of young people
they've got a you know parents have got
a real
dilemma because a lot of the pools prior
to the covid
um had a three-year waiting list on
their um
on their swimming program so it doesn't
take a mathematician to figure out that
they're going to be a lot of kids that
will
will uh will not be able to learn how to
swim
unless we can get those balls open and
and fully operational as
quickly as possible
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back with us this morning to
take us through the newspapers the
journalist and broadcaster vidisha and
the comedian
andrew doyle morning again to you both
um starting with the
i front page and andrew you've had a
look at this story really the question
that everyone's asking
when are we going to be out of lockdown
and uh you know what will the roadmap be
out of our restrictions that's right and
finally downing street have outlined a
kind of
what they're calling a road map for us
to get out of lockdown uh boris
johnson's described this as a
three-stage plan
so what would happen is he's hoping that
by the easter weekend by april the pubs
will be open again
and you'll start seeing uh the
hospitality industry coming back
to life by the eighth of march then he's
talking about um
reopening of schools that's when that's
scheduled for
and then at that point he would or they
would assess the r
number and as we all know the key r
number is the rate of infection
that has to be under one actually
yesterday was the first time since july
that the r number had gone below one um
but that's what they would be looking
for on the eighth of march as the
schools are scheduled to reopen
if it is below 1 then they can proceed
to the next stage and they would give
the green light for
non-essential shops to be opening by the
end of march so i think the
this road map idea is really really
important because
ultimately the economy is taking such a
big hit businesses
shops teachers and parents uh everyone
needs to know or have some sense
at least of when all these restrictions
uh can be lifted not least because
people need hope that this is going to
be not going to be something that's
going on
interminably i should say that the
government's roadmap is a best-case
scenario so boris johnson has said that
it's very unlikely that for instance
uh travel to foreign countries will be
open for many many months
to come but this is a really good step
forward i think no one's denying the
seriousness of the virus
but we also have to be clear that there
is a very there are very serious costs
to restrictions on the liberty of
citizens and we've tried the new normal
we do
have to get back to the normal normal
yes uh sounded very positive especially
with the art rate being
under one for the first time since july
but the male's saying badisha that we
shouldn't bank on
on freedom in time for easter
yes this follows on completely from what
andrew was saying and the male also
referred to this roadmap in fact we know
that boris johnson is usually a
in a brilliant optimistic type but this
intervention has really come from the
government's
own scientists who are pointing out that
despite coming out of the gate really
early on the vaccines
we still need to get these very high
infection numbers coming down
and to realize that for every household
to get the two doses
of the vaccine that they need will
really see us into
autumn so instead of trying to book
summer holidays
or easter holidays i mean remember that
even germany
uh today very recently in the last
couple of days
has put travel restrictions on on
neighboring countries
uh citizens traveling in so these are
still very very hot
issues we are not really in a steep
decline
of the latest wave of covid so they're
warning that we shouldn't really make
plans of course i agree completely with
andrew that
this lock down this pandemic this
quarantine whatever you want to call it
normal life for most people stopped
around the 13th of march
last year so we're really nearly
approaching the one year anniversary
of this strange unnatural way that we've
all been living
but it's also true that if you look at
the reality of the numbers of infections
and deaths
and you look at how far in we've got to
that full
course of vaccinations we're not quite
where we need to be yet
what's interesting is that boris johnson
is clearly listening to the science a
lot of his bluster has gone a lot of his
sort of
don't worry about it it's all going to
be okay snappiness has gone and he's
been really quite
sober indeed somewhat invisible i'd say
over the last
two weeks but the overall message is
don't look to easter or summer
try to think of embracing what i'm
calling autumn term
that period after the summer holidays
look ahead to them
okay let's move away from the pandemic
with this story andrew about a teacher
uh forced out of her job by pushy
parents the story says
yes this is uh sue allington who is a
teacher at
rose hill school in tunbridge wells
which is a prestigious
prep school and she was dismissed uh
because parents put in complaints that
she wasn't sufficiently qualified
she's actually been awarded 140 000
pounds in this tribunal
and and rightly so now uh sue allington
uh was considered an excellent teacher
across the board there were no problems
at all
um um but simply because the the parents
in question had said she didn't have the
formal qualification she didn't have a
formal
teacher training degree so she had a
levels and no more but she started work
at a time
when that was a possible career route so
she started as a games teacher and moved
into the
the academic aspect of school life um so
this is just frankly parents behaving
like jobs worth this is just bureaucracy
these parents had even sent her thank
you notes because she was such a good
teacher so this is absolutely uh
preposterous frankly and then the
headmistress had told her
she'd have to become a ta a teaching
assistant and take a massive pay cut
and she challenged this and it's it's
good that justice has been served here
i've
i should point out i've done teacher
training i used to be a teacher i hate
to break it to you
teacher training degrees are just
jumping through hoops you learn how to
be a good teacher
on the job and frankly private schools
should just tell pushy parents to back
off
because they can they get in they get
involved when they shouldn't they don't
know anything about education
and frankly heads should just be
sticking by their teachers these are
unreasonable complaints
thank you so you feel quite strongly on
that on that one
vested interest there bedisha this story
about
the kids company uh boss and a judge
rejecting
a bid to disqualify
yeah this is actually another story of
unjustified complaints and a good woman
vindicated you might remember
kids company a few years ago really
being a beacon when it comes to reaching
out
to um those who are excluded very
very vulnerable young people young
people who'd had very tough lives
kids company was brought down by
unsubstantiated sexual abuse and
financial mismanagement
claims and the reason i'm bringing up
now is because after three and a half
year legal battle the woman who is the
founder
of kids company camila batmanglitch who
is who was a real heroine in public life
and seven trustees have finally been
completely exonerated
it's so important now because what
covett has done is increase social
inequality and poverty and
makes circumstances much much worse for
those who are socially excluded as
indeed marcus
rashford's campaigning has pointed out
we need
charities like kids company more than
ever to reach those who are
unreachable who've fallen through the
cracks who can't get the help and the
support
that they need and that's why i'm so
delighted i just wanted to bring this up
because three and a half year legal
battle of course it fell off the front
pages
but we need companies like we need
organizations like kids company
and children's charities more than ever
at this time
complete gear change now um tell us
about the dog
stranded in mexico andrew
i like this story because when it comes
to tenuous star wars connections you've
got to hand it to the sun
uh this is a dog that is called
chewbacca it's a nine-month-old shih tzu
it's absolutely beautiful you can see
the picture of it there
uh and of course the the article is
based on the concept that it looks
resembles
chewbacca from star wars and you can see
a picture of chewbacca there this poor
dog
was stranded in mexico because they'd
lost the pet passport
i i wasn't even sure that these things
existed but apparently um
it's a married couple both called karen
karen and karen
so that's a bit confusing um but karen
as in the female of the partners stayed
behind in mexico because she was trying
to find the pet passport
and the poor little dog chewie uh was
left out there and there's been a big um
big hoo-ha and finally uh chewbacca is
able to come back to the uk so it's
a triumph um but let's face it the only
reason this is being reported is because
there's a slight connection
with star wars okay chewie's on his
way home um just very quickly
valentine's day tomorrow this is the
ultimate story in recycling
bedisha it's super duper cute so tom
mccannister who was a sailor he met his
lovely wife jean
white for 61 years many many moons ago
and he presented her back then with a
valentine's card he
preserved it lovingly and every
valentine's day
it reappears on the mantelpiece wherever
they are living at the time jean herself
has said our kids think it's daft
but i love him to bits for it so bless
them i'm sure it means the same
every single year but ish and andrew
scene the next hour good to see
you